THAT BRINGS US TO THE NEXT
GAME, PETER HARDWICK FACTS.
NOW --
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
SO I WANT TO EXPLAIN THIS GAME A
LITTLE BIT.
TODAY I AM CELEBRATING 11 YEARS
OF SOBRIETY, OCTOBER 8TH TODAY.
IT'S ACTUALLY THE 9TH --
[CHEERS AND APPLUASE]
SO, YEAH, 11 YEARS AGO I QUIT
DRINKING AND I DON'T SAY THAT SO
PEOPLE ARE LIKE, HEY, PAT ON THE
BACK SO YOU CAN JERK OFF MY EGO.
I AM SAYING THAT TO YOU BECAUSE
IF YOU ARE STRUGGLING, IF YOU
ARE HAVING A PROBLEM, GET
COUNSELING IF YOU ARE ON THE
FENCE GET HELP, YOU CAN DO IT
AND GODDAMNIT, YOU DESERVE
IT, YOU ABSOLUTELY ARE WORTH IT
SO TAKE CARE OF YOURSELF.
ALL RIGHT?
[ CHEERS AND APPLAUSE ]
>> Chris: MAYBE ONE DAY YOU WILL
ALSO HOST AN INTERNET SHOW WITH
DICK JOKES, WHO KNOWS.
BUT AS I'M SURE MANY PEOPLE IN
RECOVERY WILL TELL YOU, I
FEEL LIKE A COMPLETLY DIFFERENT
PERSON.
AND THANKFULLY, I THINK I LOOK
LIKE A DIFFERENT PERSON.
THIS IS WHAT I LOOKED LIKE IN
2003.
ALL RIGHT, THAT IS, UM, THAT IS
MY EX-GIRLFRIEND RIGHT THERE.
I REFER TO THIS VERSION OF
MYSELF AS PETER HARDWICK.
HERE IS ANOTHER ONE.
OH, NO.
A TOTALLY DIFFERENT GUY.
YOU DIDN'T EVEN REACT THAT
WAY TO THE MURDER CLOWN
PICTURES.
I DON'T KNOW.
EVERYTHING WAS PRETTY HAZY BACK
THEN BUT I WANT YOU GUYS TO
REMIND ME BY GIVING ME FACTS
ABOUT THIS HARD-DRINKING PETER
HARDWICK FELLOW. OKAY?
I'M GONNA PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK, STARTING NOW AND GO.
T.J.
>> PETER HARDWICK,THE ONLY
MAN MADE COMPLETELY OF CADBURY
EGGS.
>> Chris: I DO SEEM TO RECALL
THAT, POINTS.
SARA.
>> PETER HARDWICK, LOOKS LIKE
ALL THE MEMBERS OF WILSON
PHILLIPS COMBINED INTO ONE
PERSON.
>> Chris: POINTS.
CASH.
>> PRIME MINISTER OF CANADA,
1981 THROUGH 1993.
>> Chris: POINTS.
SARA.
>> ONCE MADE OUT WITH DANE
CORTIZE IN THE DUG OUT ON AN
EPISODE OF ROCK AND JOCK.
>> Chris: POINTS.
TJ.
I MISS YOU DAN. TJ.
>> PETER HARDWICK WENT THROUGH
EVERY SINGLE HAIRSTYLE FROM
ALL THE BOY BANDS ON THE 1980S
>> Chris: YES, HE DID.
ALL THE WAY.
SARA.
>> IF YOU HELD A MATCH UP NEXT
TO HIS SKIN, PETER HARDWICK
WOULD ERUPT INTO FLAMES LIKE A
BAKED ALASKA.
>> Chris: YES. THAT'S RIGHT.
POINTS.
HE WAS JUST LIKE FLASH PAPER.
POINTS. CASH.
>> HE WAS ABDUCTED BY ALIENS.
IMMEDIATELY RETURNED.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]